support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
I'll move university comm the link will
be in the description below thank you
and enjoy alright so next up is energy
earlier we talked about physical and
chemical changes those physical and
chemical changes have energy changes
associated with them so we need to know
what is energy energy is simply the
ability to do work and work equals Force
Times distance which you may have
learned if you take in physics already
but if you don't that's what it is I'm
not gonna get into the details of that
but so for right now energy is the
ability to do work and energy there's
all this this equation associated with
energy and that is e subscript T equals
ke plus PE so what are these things ke
and PE and what is et et stands for
energy total or total energy and that is
the total energy and object has ke is
kinetic energy which is energy
associated with motion so we're talking
about the energy of an object the part
of it is going to be due to the energy
of motion the last thing is PE PE is
potential energy and potential energy is
the energy due to the position of the
object so the idea here is that the
total energy of any object or system is
equal to the total kinetic energy plus
the total potential energy those two
values added together will give you the
total energy and object has now
something that's really really important
to understand is that energy is
conserved and that is the first law of
thermodynamics another way to actually
say that is that energy cannot be
created or destroyed it can only change
form so there are tons of different
types of energies you can be talking
about heat energy kinetic energy or
potential energy as we saw up here
there's
we can talk about chemical potential
energy we thought there's a million
different things maybe not a million but
the point is there's a bunch of
different types of energies that what
you think about another thing that's
very another thing excuse me that is
very important is to realize that when
you talk a lot about reactions in nature
nature tends towards stability and
stability really is lower energy
situations and that hopefully makes some
intuitive sense if you want to think
about it like this think about like a
toddler or a young child if they're if
they're stable if they're not really
moving around a lot they're probably
it's probably because you know they're
tire they got low energy right but if
you give them some candy and they get
all hyper they're all kinds of unstable
so that's kind of a simple way to kind
of think about this idea is that
stability and lower energy tend to go
hand-in-hand it the lack of stability
things that are unstable are higher on
energy
okay so let's think about some
situations which involve the kinetic
energy in potential energy first example
involves gravity so let's imagine this
guy is holding a bowling ball ten meters
in the air because he's gigantic and
super tall so he's holding a bowling
ball at rest so at rest means no
movement right no movement
which means there's no energy due to
motion okay so that means there's no
kinetic energy at this point up here at
this height however because this ball is
up in the air you can imagine that it
has a certain amount of potential energy
right if this guy lets it go this thing
will drop right so at this point due to
its height this thing has gravitational
potential energy so it has all of all
the energy that has its potential energy
none of its kinetic because it's not
moving
however this guy lets it go and it drops
it'll go down to the ground
as its falling potential energy that
used to have right the lower it goes the
less potential energy it has right if
this thing is falling its potential
energy is decreasing and and the kinetic
energy
is increasing oops kinetic energy is
increasing so essentially the potential
energy is being sort of converted into
kinetic energy as this thing is falling
right so at the top here up at this
height it's got all potential energy and
no kinetic energy this is not a very
stable situation right this thing could
fall it hurt your toe oh no that's right
it's not very stable situation it's less
stable but things that this thing Falls
all the way to the ground at the point
of impact if no longer has potential
energy all of the potential energy that
it had up at this height has been
converted oops to kinetic energy so I
wrote that down wrong there I meant to
put has no more potential energy right
all of it is now kinetic and so as soon
as it impacts the ground the ground will
kind of absorb this energy and now we've
got this bowling ball and it's pretty
stable right so this is a situation in
which nature is sort of allowing this
this to tend toward a more stable
situation okay so that's something that
is studied in physics gravitational
stuff and whatnot not going to get into
the details
another thing that's discussed in
physics but it's also relevant and
relatable to chemistry is the idea
what's going on with Springs so if you
can imagine a spring that is where both
of its ends are connected to little
blocks all right like this let's just
say that this spring has a block on
either side and these are just identical
blocks and this spring is kind of just
relaxed right or at equilibrium as we
say we can do two things so we can
either take these blocks and sort of
squeeze them together right if we take
our hands let me push them right you
imagine somebody's hand pushing this and
and and pushing this right you can kind
of squeeze them together in like this
right and now you've compressed the
spring so now what does this spring want
to do it wants to go back to the relaxed
position right it wants to go
to being relaxed throughout equilibrium
so what it has is it has increased
potential energy this potential energy
can become kinetic as soon as these
these hands let go and this thing will
want to go back to its relaxed form so
that that potential energy is when this
thing is compressed if we let it go that
potential energy will be will turn into
kinetic energy to get it back to this
relaxed position on the flip side we
could do the opposite we could we can
stretch the spring right we can instead
of compressing it like heat like we did
here we can also stretch it by pulling
the blocks away from each other
so this spring is no longer relaxed
right it also has an increased potential
energy right as soon as we let it go
it'll spring back into to its relaxed
position which is what it wants to do
and so again that increased potential
energy can go back to becoming kinetic
now the reason why I discussed this is
because this is similar to basically
what happens to charged particles which
is I'm actually the next example that's
a little bit more relevant to to some of
the basics of chemistry so here
something that we have to know about
charged particles before we really
discuss them is that this this important
simple fact that opposite charges
attract and like charges repel and you
should never ever forget this do not
forget this opposite charges attract and
like charges repel and you might think
you know why is this why is it that
opposite charges attract and like
charges repel the answer is again that
nature tends towards stability and
charges naturally are not stable things
like to be neutral neutrality is stable
so just imagine these two different
situations if you take a plus charge a
plus one charge and a minus one charge
put them together you get zero charge
right and so together they're neutral
which is stable or lower and energy less
energy right but if you take two plus
charges you get a plus two charge also
you could have put negative
one short two negative one charges to
get negative to the point is that here
you start off with plus charge and a
plus charge to two individually just
plus one together is plus two sets
together you have you know you'll have
something neutral you have more charge
or charge and you began with right which
is which is less stable than what you
had before just two individual charges
right so this is unstable or higher
energy more energy so the reason why I'm
opposite charges attract is because they
can come together to to give neutrality
or stability and like charges will repel
from each other because together they
just make more charge and and that's
unstable nature doesn't tend toward less
stability it tends toward stability so
opposite charges attract like charges
repel and so if we imagine that we have
two like charges and what we could do is
we let's just this example here in 3a is
very similar to compressing the two
blocks connected to the spring together
they don't really want to be together
these like charges if I push them
together right I push this to push these
together and I have them close together
now obviously I wouldn't do this with my
hands you can't just take a charge and
push it to charges and push them
together with your hands but if you
imagine that you take two charged
particles of that had to like charge and
you push them together they don't really
want to be together right that's more
charged less stable so they want to get
out of that so what would happen is that
they would want they would repel and
that's an important fact when it comes
to to studying chemistry where as the
the opposite case right taking two
opposing charges positive and negative
they're they like to hang out together
right if you pulled them apart if you
pulled them apart to get to this
situation here where you have a plus
charge out here to the left oh the
negative charge out here the left
they're going to want to come back
together so they're gonna if you let
them go they're going to want to come
back together so that's charged
particles are really really important
when studying chemistry one last example
that's not really like the others but an
important idea to kind of keep in mind
that is the idea of food food has energy
we everyone knows this right we eat food
for energy and the food that we have is
made up of macromolecules called
carbohydrates fats or proteins which
some people know some people may not
know but the reason we get energy from
these foods is because these molecules
these components contain what's called
chemical potential energy and and that
is stored in those molecules as a result
the attractions and repulsions of the
charged particles within them so the
details of which we're not going to
cover right now but the idea here is
that what we do is we eat foods that
have chemical potential energy and we
take this chemical potential energy and
we turn it into an energy that's usable
for us usable energy and then we use
that energy to of course go about and do
whatever with whatever our bodies need
need it for so so the idea here is just
kind of discuss how energy relates to
some things in our lives
hope that video is helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
be sure to fiddle with the like and
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already also be sure to share the video
with anyone you think might find it
helpful thanks and happy studying